the last time I heard my son's voice was
when he walked out the front door on his
way to school
he called out one word in the darkness
bye
it was April 20 20th 1999 later that
morning at Columbine High School my son
Dylan and his friend Eric killed 12
students and a teacher and wounded more
than 20 others before taking their own
life 13 innocent people were killed
leaving their loved ones in a state of
grief and trauma others sustained
injuries some resulting in disfigurement
and permanent disability but the
enormity of the tragedy can be measured
only by the number of deaths and
injuries that took place
there's no way to quantify the
psychological damage of those who are in
the school or who took part in rescue or
cleanup efforts
there's no way to assess the magnitude
of a tragedy like Columbine especially
when it can be a blueprint for other
shooters who go on to commit atrocities
of their own Columbine was a tidal wave
and when the crash ended it would take
years for the community and for society
to comprehend its impact it has taken me
years to try to accept my son's legacy
the cruel behavior that defined the end
of his life showed me that he was a
completely different person from the one
I knew afterwards people asked how could
you not know what kind of a mother were
you I still ask myself those same
questions before the shootings I thought
of myself as a good mom helping my
children become caring healthy
responsible adults was the most
important role in my life
but the tragedy convinced me that I
failed as a parent
and it's partially the sense of failure
that brings me here today
aside from his father I was the one
person who knew and loved Dylan the most
if anyone could have known what was
happening it should have been me right
but I didn't know today I'm here to
share the experience of what it's like
to be the mother of someone who kills
and hurts for years after the tragedy I
comb through memories trying to figure
out exactly where I failed as a parent
but there are no simple answers I can't
give you any solutions all I can do is
share what I have learned when I talk to
people who didn't know me before the
shootings I have three challenges to
meet first when I walk into a room like
this I never know if someone there has
experienced loss because of what my son
did I feel a need to acknowledge the
suffering caused by a member of my
family who wasn't here to do it for
himself
so first with all of my heart I'm sorry
if my son has caused you pain the second
challenge I have is that I must ask for
understanding and even compassion when I
talk about my son's death as a suicide
two years before he died he wrote on a
piece of paper in a notebook that he was
cutting himself he said that he was in
agony and wanted to get a gun so he
could end his life I didn't know about
any of this until months after his death
when I talked about his death as a
suicide I'm not trying to downplay the
viciousness he showed at the end of his
life I'm trying to understand how his
suicidal thinking led to murder after a
lot of reading and talking with experts
I've come to believe that his
involvement in the shootings was rooted
not in his desire to
but in this desire to die the third
challenge I have when I talk about my
son's murder-suicide is that I'm talking
about mental health excuse me is that
I'm talking about mental health or brain
health as I prefer to call it because
it's more concrete and in the same
breath I'm talking about violence the
last thing I want to do was to
contribute to the misunderstanding that
already exists around mental illness
only a very small percent of those who
have a mental illness are violent toward
other people but of those who die by
suicide it's estimated that about 75 to
maybe more than 90% have a diagnosis of
a mental health condition of some kind
as you all know very well our mental
health care system is not equipped to
help everyone and not everyone with
destructive thoughts fits the criteria
for a specific diagnosis many who have
ongoing feelings of fear or anger or
hopelessness are never assessed or
treated too often they get our attention
only if they reach a behavioral crisis
if estimates are correct that about one
to two percent of all suicides involves
the murder of another person when
suicide rates rise as they are rising
for some populations then murder suicide
rates will rise as well I wanted to
understand what was going on in Dylan's
mind prior to his death so I look for
answers from other survivors of suicide
loss I did research and volunteered to
help with fundraising events and
whenever I could I talked with those who
had survived their own suicidal crisis
or attempt one of the most helpful
conversations I had was with a co-worker
who overheard me talking to someone else
in my office cubicle she heard me say
that Dylan could not have loved me if he
could do something that's horror
as he did later when she found me alone
she apologized for overhearing that
conversation but told me that I was
wrong she said that when she was a young
single mother with three small children
she became severely depressed and was
hospitalized to keep her safe at the
time she was certain that her children
would be better off if she died so she
had made a plan to end her life she
assured me that a mother's love was the
strongest bond on earth and that she
loved her children more than anything in
the world but because of her illness she
was sure that they would be better off
without her what she said and what I've
learned from others is that we do not
make the so-called decision or choice to
die by suicide in the same way that we
choose what car to drive or where to go
on a Saturday night when someone is in
an extremely suicidal state they are in
a stage for medical health emergency
you're thinking is impaired and they've
lost access to tools of self-governance
even though they can make a plan and ask
this logic their sense of truth is
distorted by a filter of pain through
which they interpret their reality some
people can be very good at hiding this
state and they often have good reasons
for doing that many of us have suicidal
thoughts at some point but persistent
ongoing thoughts of suicide and devising
a means to die our symptoms of pathology
and like many illnesses the condition
has to be recognized and treated before
a life is lost but my son's death was
not purely a suicide it involves mass
murder I wanted to know how his suicidal
thinking became homicidal but research
is sparse and there are no simple
answers yes he probably had ongoing
depression
he had a personality that was
perfectionistic and self-reliant and
that made him less likely to seek help
from others he had experience triggering
events at the school that left him
feeling debased and humiliated and mad
and he had a complicated friendship with
a boy who shared his feelings of rage
and alienation and who was seriously
disturbed controlling and homicidal and
on top of this period in his life of
extreme vulnerability and fragility
Dylan found access to guns even though
we'd never owned any in our home it was
appallingly easy for a 17 year old boy
to buy guns both legally and illegally
without my permission or knowledge and
somehow 17 years in many school
shootings later it's still appallingly
easy what Dylan did that day broke my
heart and as trauma so often does it
took a toll on my body and on my mind
two years after the shootings I got
breast cancer and two years after that I
began to have mental health problems on
top of the constant perpetual grief I
was terrified but I would run into a
family member of someone Dylan had
killed or be accosted by depressed or by
an angry citizen I was afraid to turn on
the news afraid to hear myself being
called a terrible parent or a disgusting
person I started having a panic attack
the first bout started four years after
the shootings when I was getting ready
for the depositions and would have to
meet the victims families face to face
the second round started six years after
the shootings when I was preparing to
speak publicly about
suicide for the first time at a
conference both episodes lasted several
weeks the attacks happened everywhere in
the hardware store in my office or even
while reading a book in bed my mind
would suddenly lock into the same cycle
of terror and no matter how hard I tried
to calm myself down or reason my way out
of it I couldn't do it it felt as if my
brain was trying to kill me and then
being afraid of being afraid
consumed all of my thoughts that's when
I learned firsthand what it feels like
to have a malfunctioning mind and that's
when I truly became a brain health
advocate with therapy and medication and
self-care life eventually returned to
whatever could be thought of as normal
under the circumstances when I look back
on all that had happened I could see
that my son's spiral into dysfunction
probably occurred over a period of about
two years plenty of time to get him help
if only someone had known that he needed
help and known what to do every time
someone asks me how could you not have
known it feels like a punch in the gut
it carries accusations and taps into my
feelings of guilt that no matter how
much therapy I've had I will never fully
eradicate but here's something I've
learned if love were enough to stop
someone who was suicidal from hurting
themselves suicides would hardly ever
happen but love is not enough and
suicide is prevalent it's the second
leading cause of death for people aged
10 to 34 and 15 percent of American
youths report having made a suicide plan
in the last year
I've learned that no matter how much we
want to believe we can we cannot know
our control everything our loved ones
think and feel and the stubborn belief
that we are somehow different that
someone we love would never think of
hurting themselves or someone else can
cause us to miss what's hidden in plain
sight
and if worst-case scenarios do come to
pass
we'll have to learn to forgive ourselves
for not knowing for not asking the right
questions
are not finding the right treatment we
should always assume that someone we
love may be suffering regardless of what
they say or how they act we should
listen with our whole being without
judgment and without offering solutions
I know that I will live with this
tragedy with these multiple tragedies
for the rest of my life I know that in
the minds of many what I lost can't
compare to what the other families lost
I know my struggle doesn't make there's
any easier I know there are even some
who think I don't have the right to any
pain but only to a life of permanent
penance in the end what I know comes
down to this the tragic fact is that
even the most vigilant and responsible
of us may not be able to help but for
love sakes we must never stop trying to
know the unknowable thank you